hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm gonna answer a question from
one of our readers Dave who is an
inventor created a product about 15
years ago and got burned somebody
basically took his idea ran with it and
made money and he got kinda screwed over
there and now he's worried about sharing
his new ideas and being able to build a
business off of them so one of my advice
on what to do so Dave my advice you do
have to be cautious with who you tell
your business idea to so you don't want
to broadcast it everywhere online and
clearly lay out exactly how you're gonna
be successful with your company but at
the same time you can't do everything
yourself and you don't see successful
entrepreneurs do everything themselves
so you're gonna have to go out and get
help and if you don't tell people about
your idea noticin be able to help you
out and if you horde it yourself you're
not really able to turn it into a
successful business so you're going to
have to tell some people about it and
recognize that you need help beyond what
you know how to do with your business so
with every entrepreneur every successful
story you see that they've gone out and
gotten people to join them and help them
and you know they build a business
together so you will have to go out and
tell people about it and I appreciate
that you've been burned in the past and
it could be difficult for you to get out
there and you know trust people but
that's gonna be part of the the process
because if you don't do it you're gonna
hold on to it yourself and you're not
gonna be able to turn it into a
successful business
so you do have to get out there you do
have to tell people about the business
idea and recognize that the the benefits
of telling people and they ought to
somebody be able to help you out far
outweigh the risk of somebody coming up
and taking the idea and running with it
the execution is far more important than
the idea for most businesses so it's
more about how you run with
idea than the idea itself and to do that
you need a really qualified team around
you so you have some expertise that you
bring to the table you you know created
the idea you have some ideas on how to
make it work but you're going to have to
surround yourself with the team who can
help you take that up to that next step
so hopefully that's convinced you to
want to get out there a little bit and
share your idea obviously you want to be
a little bit cautious over who you share
it with but you you will have to get out
there and tell people about the idea so
I hope that helps date everybody else if
you like the video please give it a
thumbs up I love seeing those thumbs up
come in and if you have any other
thoughts to add to this please out a
comment build a video and we'll see you
on the next episode
you